les autorités sanitaires ont elle agit
efficacement contre l'épidémie de covin
19 y at il eu certains manquements c'est
à ces questions qu'un groupe de 60
citoyens principalement des familles de
résidents en ehpad ainsi que cinq
associations souhaitent avoir des
réponses pour cela ils ont déposé une
demande en référé au tribunal judiciaire
de paris
plus globalement ils souhaitent
comprendre l'absence de masques au
premier semestre de l'année 2020 mais
aussi les critères qui ont permis
l'hospitalisation ou non de personnes
âgées atteint du coc vite 19
certains dénoncent aussi l'utilisation
durer votre île dans des ehpad je
propose d'écouter ces témoignages
il ya eu des mensonges donc
collectivement on demande des comptes
sur les masques tri des malades
les reçus de spi et individuellement
chacun d'entre nous donc familles
associations soient des associations
avec nous bien sûr on implique nos
directeurs de structures mois on
directeur d'ehpad au delà d'avoir menti
il n'a pas répondu à mes questions
on doit
savoir ce qu'il s'est passé il doit y
avoir de la transparence et droit qu'à
voir la fluidité sans transparence il
n'y a pas de confiance
voilà pourquoi moi mais gentil suis
engagé ma mère est décédée le 4 avril
elle est décédée
je pense à la suite de dury votre hymne
qui lui a été administré la veille au
soir
sans notre consentement sans le sien non
plus il s'agit pour eux d'une première
étape il souhaite que la justice ordonne
la transmission de divers documents de
la part d'organismes de santé comme des
hôpitaux est des ehpad mais aussi la rs
l'agencé régionale de santé
d'ile-de-france le but examiné eux mêmes
tous ces documents pour éventuellement
intenter des actions je vous propose
d'écouter l'avocat des requérants c'est
ce qu'on appelle un référé probatoire il
s'agit de réunir des preuves des
informations qui permettront ensuite
d'orienter une éventuelle action en
justice
et ça va dépendre un petit peu d'époque
nous allons récupérer
monsieur caussimont a perdu sa maman
l'année dernière dans un ehpad à pantin
et il a l'impression que c'était pas ne
va pas mais toutes les informations
concernant les causes ou les
la fin de huit cents ans donc par cette
procédure il espère récupérer bien
évidemment d'abord le rapport médical le
dossier médical mais surtout il veut
vérifier que la procédure mise en place
par la loi claisse leonetti sur la fin
de vie a été respectée parce que
monsieur connu au simone n'a pas été
consulté pour le placement sous rivotril
de savants or le rivotril c'est un
produit extrêmement puissant dont
l'objectif final est de placer un
sédation profonde terminale c'est bien
d'amener dans la mort une personne c'est
un exemple de questions qui vont se
poser aujourd'hui le tribunal judiciaire
de paris se penche donc sur cette action
aujourd'hui d'après leur avocat ils
s'attendaient à une mise en délibéré